so many of us find teens glued to their
phone their computer their ipad but how
often are we checking to see what's
going on behind those screens well it's
a topic that we looked into after police
say a girl was drugged and raped by 25
year old george duran she met him on
snapchat victoria saha talked with
experts and a local mother who was
taking extreme precautions to keep her
teens safe
it's 2022 and there are so many new apps
out there like twitch roblox and discord
on top of the other social media apps
that have already been around although
these platforms may seem innocent it
opens the door for possible dangers for
your child if you aren't monitoring them
because that's
natalie wainwright isn't taking any
chances when it comes to monitoring her
children's phone use i can track them
with their location and i can see the
phone calls after hours and the techs
that are coming in and out it is it is
it's so helpful because i get an inside
look into what they're doing she uses an
app called smart family and just this
week she took her 13 year old son's
phone away after she found conversations
between an adult and her teen son
although it wasn't anything
inappropriate it still concerned her why
are there adults talking to children why
are there i just there's zero and then i
have killed why didn't i catch it
earlier wainwright says she tracks her
kid's phone so she can be aware of what
they could be googling or who they're
talking to then maybe once a month i
actually go through it
which i feel guilty when i do it but i
found out a lot about my son this way
she can approach her children about a
difficult topic that they might not have
talked to anyone about kids are googling
about suicide kids are googling really
tough topics we cannot let our guard
down doctors said karana said it's okay
for parents to be ahead of the game how
does a parent do all that without
becoming too overbearing that's a really
good question um you just have to be a
good enough parent you don't have to be
a perfect parent so safety comes first a
tip i got from other parents is try
friending or following your teen's
social media so you can be up to date on
what they post and see who's commenting
also reach out to your phone provider to
see what options they have to monitor
your team's phone victoria zaha live
local now